undocumented immigrant arrested just
before his high school prom has failed
in his effort to win extra time in the
u.s. lawyers for Diego Puma McCann SIA
say immigration authorities yesterday
denied the request for a stay of removal
the 19 year old and his mother faced
deportation back to Ecuador
Toni de copal shows us what led to their
arrest Toni good morning good morning
Diego Puma Macan say it was expected to
walk in his high school graduation
ceremony this weekend and he was just
hours away from attending his senior
prom but instead one day after his
mother was taken by immigration
authorities he found himself cowering in
a closet in his cousin's home while
agents prepared to arrest him we thought
like they're going to break the doors
federal agents came to Gaby Malkin say
as Ossining New York home last Thursday
looking for her cousin Diego Puma Malkin
SIA it's really scary because it's your
own house
it's supposed to be safe there the 19
year old had spent the night after his
mother Rosa was detained by immigration
authorities the previous day Diego and
his mother left their native Ecuador in
2014 immigrating from Mexico through
Texas to New York according to ice they
were told by an immigration judge last
November to leave the US the ice agents
were wearing on vests that said police
on the back Ossining 'he's mayor
Victoria Garrity saw agents surrounding
the house all the incidents we'd been
aware of in the past involved folks that
were believed to be dangerous and in
this case it feels very different Diego
and his mother don't seem dangerous to
us if you're violating the law you
should be uncomfortable he should be
looking over his shoulder at a hearing
on Capitol Hill this week New York
congresswoman Nita Lowey who represents
Ossining asked acting ice director
Thomas Holman whether the teen was on a
priority list so you're going after a
student who's graduating and is law
abiding star law-abiding he violated law
and was told by an immigration judge you
must leave and he failed to do so
according to Gabby Malkin saya
agents threatened other members of her
family so they said give us Diego or we
take everybody yes did Diego feel like
he had to give himself up to save the
family
he hawked me he said by god we have
thing this is my wallet
give it to my dad everything's gonna be
fine I'm gonna be fine
has what happened to Diego and your on
changed the way you think of America
that make us a good country it's a good
country for all migrant or immigrant
Gaby was brought to the US as a child
and is protected under the Obama era
DREAM Act ice-rich bar disputes her
version of events saying family members
were never threatened with removal and
that this was a targeted enforcement
family's legal counsel reports at Diego
and his mother are now in the same
facility in New York after the feds had
initially kept them in separate
facilities thanks to twenty-two couple
thanks very much